our next presenter has founded five
charities for children who are seriously
ill homeless or in foster care his 25
films include Arlington Road wild Tom
and Viv and revenge of the nerds of
course presenting the award to Justin
piss pieszecki is peter Samuelsson
we first meet our young chef at the top
of his game he's 24 years old and he is
the executive chef of the White House
but this White House is not an Aaron
Sorkin kind of a White House it's more
house of cards it's more the President
as Macbeth and then there's Lady Macbeth
and they are the little Macbeth's it's
not a good place the president of the
French Republic comes on an official
state visit and there is to be a banquet
and the French president requests a rare
and very special recipe of oak cuisine
which is the author land the songbird
but the recipe requires that the bird be
tortured all of them be tortured because
it's a banquet and you eat these birds
which are tiny you eat them whole and
they must be tortured by being blinded
and then drowned slowly in Armagnac and
our young chef is disgusted and he won't
do it and they fire him they fire him
and we next meet him as the cook in
charge of three meals a day for 200
inmates convicts in a penitentiary in
North Carolina and amongst them a dozen
or so men who have been condemned to
death but before each of these men die
they get their last meal and because he
is the chef each of these meals is a
statement of civilization and of beauty
in the face of bureaucratically imposed
death duck confit charcuterie in a
Madeira wine reduction with foie gras
and of course our chef becomes a little
bit famous because it's in the newspaper
it's on the eleven o'clock news the
anchors can't even pronounce it and then
the world turns and this becomes it was
already in
ordinary script but the third act is one
of the most remarkable pieces of writing
that I've ever read because our hero
comes to believe that one of the
condemned man is actually innocent and
it does not sit well with him and this
ordinary man faced with an extraordinary
moral challenge now joins a long line of
heroes in motion pictures who must stand
up Frank Capra would be proud of this
script this mr. Smith doesn't go to
Washington he goes to the state capitol
but he speaks truth to power to the
governor you sir are entitled to your
opinion but you are not entitled to your
own truth there is one truth and by the
way human decency honor and integrity
those are things and it is an
extraordinary achievement in showing to
the world through a motion picture what
we can do at our best that individual
citizenship is at the core of what makes
our democracy work and so today November
the third 2016 the Academy is happy and
I am delighted to present this nickel
fellowship in screenwriting to Justin
Piasecki who like his citizen chef the
hero and like the songbird sword to the
sky lifted his face to the Sun and sang
of beauty and truth and honor and
Citizenship and bravery may God bless
this gifted writer and his golden pen
may God bless this Academy that does so
much good work may God bless this
democracy this constitutional democracy
which stands between us and tyranny may
God bless these United repeat United may
God bless our United States of America
Justin come up here get your nickel
well I had it together and then Peter
came up I'm a little old-fashioned and
when I asked my father in law for his
blessing to marry his daughter i pled my
case by explaining I was gainfully
employed and I had a 401k and I dental
insurance and all my shots were up to
date and I had my own netflix password
not my parents so the credentials of a
responsible young man and he said yes
and immediately after I quit my job and
I forced my wife to quit hers and moved
us to California to become a
screenwriter
so sorry mr. and mrs. Coughlin but
seriously it's too late the paperwork is
already signed I think I think of all
the expectations is a big part of being
a writer you have to somehow convince an
industry of father-in-law's you know
what you're doing so sorry mr. and mrs.
Nichol but too late the paperwork has
already been signed you also have to
convince yourself you know what you're
doing and I didn't always know I still
don't always know I'm forgetting and i'm
unsure all the time but then moments
like this come along and they offer a
little bit of hope that you're not
entirely unworthy of that blessing a
moments like this would not be possible
without many many other people so I just
want to recognize how fortunate I am to
know them too mr. and mrs. Nichol and
now Greg and Joan and Emily and the
committee that has carried this
fellowship on to the other riders being
recognized tonight it was immediately
apparent how talented you all are the
performers and producers for this
evening you were the first to make a
very personal piece of imagination
tangible so thank you all my friends in
Iowa and circling back to New York Tish
West and anyone who's ever been willing
to read my pages my reps John and Jeff
thank you my family my dad for ignoring
what rated R myint and my mom tonight
was all so much her fault starting with
those big white disney VHS cases that
can double as flotation devices and my
sister who's a brutal brutal copy editor
and to my wife who when we made that
move to Los Angeles New to not bother
with wallpaper or painting the walls
because it's just going to get covered
with story posted notes and dry erase
marker anyway she never complains
instead I came home one day and saw that
she'd just gone out and bought me all
the markers thank you